citizens of the reject Nation it is a
momentous occasion John Aaron Alexander
in a video together to throw down on
some Street Fighter
1994. how you feeling bud did you are
you excited as I am I am more excited
than I could possibly imagine I'm ready
to hadouken some fools oh yeah at the
screen
speaking of hadouken leave a hadouken on
that like button as well do some kind of
crazy ass combo to the Subscribe and
notification Bell to get notified when
the next John and Aaron massive
collaboration event happens also gotta
say a big thank you to the folks over at
prepper they do a killer job chopping up
these edits every week on these movie
highlights some love over to them and as
well if you want to see all the stuff
that doesn't get cut out of the reaction
if you want the complete Street Fighter
experience come on over to patreon.com
the real rejects we got tons of movies
and shows where you can sync up and
watch along with your own copy join us
for the full experience it's a lot of
fun and uh Hey without further Ado let's
drop two coins in the machine and uh and
and and
finish him is is Moral Combat I don't
know let's watch him do it baby
that's right I like that yeah
[Music]
yes it's like a Tommy Wiseau production
we gotta get both versions of the bumper
yes although it is nice to see the OG
it's the classic or you know it's been
so long one of the many Classics it's a
good one it's a crisp one I also like
the little airplane one I would hope
they'd play all of them just like as uh
we spent money on these all right
we went to school with this kid Simon
callow is in this this is
it's gonna be the whole reaction just us
flipping out does every famous person
who's ever existed in this movie
defeating the heavily
of General M bison
Raul Julia Raul Julian 63
hostage remains
is that what Zen GIF you came from
across the world to fight me Soldier now
is your chance square up let's do this
let's go I like his puffy suit based on
Street Fighter 2 specifically okay damn
that was very quick instantaneous yes
your turn now this is the beginner
training mode where you learn the
controls
we thank you sir please oh these dudes
have potato chips for an x man those
Colonel Giles Van Dam's Colonel Gile
okay
look at yourself on television you're
six enough a [__] so look at this
you have three days if my 20 billion
dollars are not delivered by then the
hostages will die and the world will
hold you responsible oh
Carlos Blanca so you are Guile's friend
take him to the laboratory is he gonna
get like transformed this is the thing
is like because because Street Fighter
and Mortal Kombat characters will start
to swim together so I'm trying to really
keep myself on track here they blend
they're both products of the 90s and
Tekken he doesn't like women does he no
he doesn't like journalists
equal opportunity dislike it's a great
delivery on that
oh
oh oh oh what's this dude's name
the theme song we'd be wrong yeah
[Applause]
Vega that's his name that guy's got an
awesome look I I totally knew that good
evening sir God quite a party did anyone
tell you there's a curfew you've been
shot a loose city no one tells me
anything it must be hard to get around
my men have already unloaded the truck
and brought the weapons here of course I
like my games live and In Living Color
oh In Living Color let's do this where's
homie the clown let's get it let's get
into some fights oh streets and then
that would make ten Jim Carrey
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I got the real guns now it's a kind of
cool intro for Ryu and Ken with a Nerf a
literal Nerf element
my signs Twisted to serve for version
instead of Peace after I've crushed my
enemies we'll see about getting you
published that should chew you up yeah
call Penguin press
[Music]
whoa
oh no I see everything merely
educational software why does he find it
disturbing because unlike you he's not
psychology
he's not an immoral like sociopath
the brain has become a killing machine
my loyal scientists will start on his
body yes
oh my God anabolic plasma DNA mutagens
DNA mutagens
vodka drink it's like that stuff you get
like a haunted house
[Laughter]
where are you yeah
Burger
yeah like the first official Street
Fighter fight sorry I talked you into
all this I'm sorry I listened I'm sorry
bud it's weird they're they're not as
like hyper cooled up as I would expect
it yeah there's like regular smeggular
guys over here he looks like he took a
break from like his his bank job to come
kick some ass I'm on my 30 guys I gotta
get back to the uh the accounting office
oh
he's handsome dang it's like every anime
where a guy wears a mask
[Music]
love this majestic music what's the
aluminum soil ass sword nah man it's
just that sharp and shiny I love it
aluminum foil sword
[Music]
good I don't need no sword
of course this movie is a tease
give us some street fights baby
yes did I do that you roll under arrest
[Laughter]
that's awesome always say for certain is
his base is hidden somewhere here the
river Delta Region yes
okay all right this movie is going so
hard how did he get in there
get him out of there
any other new business
[Laughter]
he's the coolest dude on Earth
hands down oh he's a Death Eater oh [__]
transition dude that was a good
transition I liked it
that's the cover of a romance novel
right there 100 yeah it's missing Fabio
and like you had to complete
they didn't watch back the footage when
they recorded this yeah that's good
enough come on make it sound cool and
we're good
do Awolnation just providing all the
assets to the military All Nations let's
go Sail
[Laughter]
no wonder they're all boats it makes
sense the AWOL Nation Refugee Center
they're on some boats it's like exactly
their logo I wonder if anybody realized
that like the the A and the N are
combined but otherwise it's like the
same but they knew what they were doing
they were like we love Street Fighter
that much
are you the same as Sagat and bison or
am I right and you're different
I love this man's acting and his voice I
love all the acting
but his voice yeah Guile's voice is
supreme this is an over guile I own this
city I'm the Ripple man and you're out
of business
[Music]
the two best characters don't fight guys
flashing back to like Elementary School
it's crazy how much he looks like him
foreign
I gotta say I like the the camo colors I
don't know what you're blending into but
sitting back there it's like it is fun
the way they're making so many
characters like Collide in these crazy
situations
yes
they wouldn't kill him off
he's got to come back like does he does
he get like
modded out or something
oh smart chunley bison
and that the new a
at first order of business
Colonel guy oh
Say It Ain't So that's great news
General congratulations
[Laughter]
congratulations I love this guy why do
they still call me a warlord and mad I'm
so chill I'm the nicest guy is to create
the perfect genetic Soldier not for
power not for evil but for good yeah
like like when they made the atomic bomb
until the very planet is in the loving
grip of the packs
is that so wrong I love this it's clear
go
yes get those Melinda May skills going
let's get down to business
oh that's even better you beat me you
beat me
another homing device rolling with the
Homing
that guy oh
put it back oh my he's alive
awesome that was give you an interview
when I was alive no way I'm gonna do it
when I'm dead what
Hollywood guy over here
how long have you been laying there I
don't want a story about bison
when I'm this close I started when I was
fresh out the womb
been holding this microphone down since
day one
basic blacks not really you Prison
Breaks
okay
yes
yes do not flip
let's go for Chase
do some Jason Bourne [__] what a screw
up
what I'm sorry oh oh said the guy
no he's getting introspective he's like
what a screw-up we really screwed that
up
I feel sorry for us right now God all
right
[Music]
Cirque du so bison
very good
Capcom I see what you did there well
done I like that this universe Capcom
just makes caps
[Applause]
but how
nice
[Applause]
this has been a glow up yeah this is the
first scene not to not to slight the
Marty McFly and Doc Brown look they were
going for earlier but uh this is good oh
significant upgrade oh yeah I'm looking
at them both like okay okay
[Applause]
that's a very video game thing this way
haha let's see the color of your money I
don't know what to make of that
these guys
[Music]
Shredder masks
bison bucks bison bucks every bison
dollar will be worth five British pounds
change rate the bank of England will set
to one side kidnap their Queen
fail-proof plan you ready
no not the place in books
your admin Honda the Sumo from Hawaii
this conclave is over yes get the claw
you will die for this insults I got
10 minutes things can't get worse
what happens right before things gone it
got worse
what who would have saw that coming
because there are enemy spies everywhere
Among Us general and this may be my
final broadcast but if it is
that we have not died in vain but we
will have ends
introduction to this part of the world
oh no Bisons the God all your weapons of
death are going to be blown the Sky High
good timing on opening that door there
yes
is that an insert that they can see
I love that this movie
the approach to Dynamics is like change
the channel
that'll stop it this guy's eyebrow
acting is amazing really though it's
like every few minutes they'll go let's
take it back down to like an eight and
then let's go right back up to 15.
whoa he has to stay ready whoa
the technology of east and west while
the government scorned me the
corporations adored me that is our bar
they will talk or they will die
preferably both
[Laughter]
take the uh
to my Chambers we have decided to grant
her a private interview uh
this way attention
dehydrate yourself
these guys are good guys like us
oh snap I didn't realize they were doing
an undercover thing that I'm glad he
said that the only chance is an assault
with a small amphibious Force the main
force will come from the north while a
single vessel equipped with the latest
in stealth technology
yeah a single boat against everything
he's got
would have to be out of his mind that
ADR is that is the greatest at line read
I've ever heard
I wonder if it was even the same guy
right
[Music]
that's a very like Temple of Doom sort
of Sheen around it when you're out here
and spices
shut up oh yeah
let's go Pulp Fiction
he likes it what the [__]
it's like I trained for this this is my
exact thing man this is just Saturday
for me
the failed trombone has sounded yeah
next Yankee the tuba maybe you ought to
lie down first
damn not not to the boxer man he's gonna
knock your block off later yep
damn
lashing buddy keep on crying out I'm
Sumo brother my body could be in one
place my mind another bars bars it's
actually a very kind of neat little Sumo
inside there now you look like bison
Troopers
yep
you got him final forms
let's go you're instructed to call off
the assault we are prepared to pay the
ransom demand what will prevent him from
taking more hostages next month and
asking for 50 billion all the money in
the world
deliver these instructions to your
troops then consider yourself relieved
of your command oh you're fired so Moral
Combat with this guy the war is canceled
we can all go home bison is getting paid
off for his crimes and our friends who
have died here
will have died whose only concern is we
wrap this up freedom and justice
they get packed up but I love these
facial expressions we can all go home I
mean this is a very diverse Army very
true yeah you know like men and women of
color Street Fighter is woke and I'm
going to kick that son of a [__]
bison's ass so hard yes that the next
bison wannabe is gonna feel it yes
no who wants to go home and who wants to
go with me
[Applause]
oh my God yeah
what's up
God we are just go we are literally just
going right to war
no prep time or anything it's awesome
this this movie has like little kid and
then energy in the best way the best
possible way yeah War gathered your
small out
[Music]
oh Slave Leia way to make them leather
like that my father was the village
Magister
[Music]
bye it's my love making hat
that's my sexy cap you had him shot as
you ran away no I'm sorry
don't you feel that I don't remember any
of it damn so you can't hardly hold me
responsible
if I don't remember it didn't happen it
was the most important day of your life
but for me it was Tuesday
I mean he's aware of his own perspective
I guess I gotta give him that
is that the line it was Tuesday yeah
this shit's normal to me you guys had
one job and I don't think
oh no
if it isn't our little buddy's double
crosses
I think he said he could lead us outside
with us outside lead us outside I found
Partners who hated you as much as I did
John Wayne Gacy fainting
I said poker the clown John Wayne bison
[Laughter]
turn the sexy on since you entered this
country
you never even threw a single punch I
know women
and you
are harmless
wow bro
go Andrew Tate exactly what I wanted you
to think
yes it's time yes
there it is getting the kicks
let's go
there's a mortal a street damn it
was a Street Fighter for you there
there's a Tekken yeah there's a bloody
Roar
Capcom versus SNK how many can you name
comment below
[Music]
oh no room gas room gas pesky room gas
[Laughter]
damn you room gas Cavani Honda you're
our only hope
I love all his stuff
this is great this is my favorite movie
I love this so much it's wonderful now
if we could just get a solid romance
going it'll have literally everything a
movie needs
attention all boards stand by at attack
Vector Alpha I'll take out the enemy
radar cap ice and
[Laughter]
race
you watch the whole movie right now
family
who took this boat to West Coast Customs
whether they give the boat to exhibit
oh my God look at him
what is he becoming they're pumping him
oh is he hulking out the making of green
yeah ah
[Music]
oh memories
who's that couple getting married love
Martin Luther King this is not a racist
monster they're teaching him critical
race Theory right now
they switched over to the woke cerebral
program
she may be a hideous monster but at
least he's tolerant yeah
it's very well adjusted very intersexual
intersectional philosophy that guy
unsuccessful just like saw five damn it
approaching Bisons out of radar
perimeter prepare for stealth mode
online who's ready
they're gonna see us so we'll put down
our visors
that'll protect us and it's going down
we're going down down and earlier round
sugar we're killing them bison
look at that camo
it's actually not a an entirely bad
effect
Sono detectors and filter all inputs
detected they're jamming us you didn't
account for sonar in the water
[Music]
our defenses are locked onto you
oh
your ass is six months overdue and it's
mine get that ass
get it his death was designed to
ingratiate his spies with you
if you didn't see that did you
jeez you're a honey
you will witness firsthand the power
that you spurned
damn oh [__]
is that an actual Street Fighter console
looks like a game cabinet
oh
[Music]
reverse of what this game would be if
you were actually playing it
that's a that's amazing
[Music]
it's a street fighter baby
[Laughter]
what are you doing nothing
[Applause]
it's weird is he turning him into Martin
Luther King I guess so he's got all the
rage of like Humanity's breadth of
Destruction plus all of its greatest
tolerant philosophies
monster Luther King yeah
Blanca Luther King
[Music]
bro damn not the kidneys I like that it
that it really took a long time to load
right seems very the tech in this
breathing
you know he's not gonna be smart your
brain's the first thing to go with
oxygen deprivation
[Music]
Hulk
save him
save him from washed up Super Mario
I will break you
uh
by an elephant yo
dude
those were strategic elephants yeah a
pachyderm unit
oh
whoa oh snap oh right through the spooky
spider web
being deposited the 20 billion in my
Swiss bank
what hell no
that'll be a firm hell no on that one
hell no I repeat hell no
we set electronic and visual markers
ETA Landing Zone 12 minutes yeah it's
got the tank top I'll be ready
I'm alive you're the coolest guy ever
you'll be alive you've already thwarted
death once
you can do it again
clear I just love how customer service
that voice sounds for how Sinister the
words actually are
hostage pit hostage pit
search Ron Jeremy's dead body you might
find something you might find something
you're not a little not ready for you'll
always find something you're not ready
for it
oh no
no
steam Charlie it's me I'm your friend
William
Will i Am
oh what's that voice it's cool to get to
know William and not just guile you know
who who's the man himself right that's
good personal
oh no he's gonna put him out of his
misery dude no he's gotta have a street
fight
no no
you have no right yes
yes damn straight Dr Frankenstein
Stephanie use him
good shot you shall be killed by a wild
beast
s oh no I did what I could to preserve
his mind his mind retains the capacity
for good yes and for evil as well he's
true neutral the real monsters upstairs
he expects to see his creation surprise
him
that's a face
oh surprise [__]
yes get the kick looks so Overjoyed by
that
[Music]
oh my God damn all right I got dark real
quick
yeah sorry guys but this is for your own
protection
please kill guyohawk right now
oh no of course
[Music]
yeah yeah get it get him get the
hostages free and I'll get you two first
class tickets home okay go
go
yes now you're getting serious we got
fan service to do my man yay
[Music]
let's go
yeah give us a street fight
[Applause]
through the floor
the cerebral programming we're expected
in here
[Music]
no cute little boy
oh yeah
get some Cooks
[Music]
so this level is like playing some kind
of big open multiplayer and a first
person shooter
[Music]
then defeat is a possibility oh no we
shall face it together DJ
what do you mean together
I don't know about all that
is that is the best that's right that's
my boy right best performance beat in
the whole movie oh my God
have fun with that upstairs
before we don't oh now you're coming
with me or not just kiss already before
this place blows up we can find
something worthwhile no thanks I already
found something worthwhile
I fight pro bono I don't understand
I don't understand
no boys can't break up now the boys need
to be back in town yeah oh they will be
they will be
let's go let's go baby
good swinging Shia
[Music]
is not gonna shoot him
don't worry you survived it was
everybody's there
don't even need to say it
uh that's fun
still no sign of bison
you really thought he was the [__] for a
second come out from behind the curtain
wizard let's see how pure your combat
really is yeah are you man enough to
fight with me come on you can't oh yes I
can if I'm not upside in 15 minutes
evacuate Without Me Love is American
flag tattoo right
damn wow he's towering over them next
I'll make you a dead one yeah
oh look at that the guns I don't even
gonna try and replicate the welcome to
the gun show hey
[Music]
sure could
yeah
yeah oh my Godzilla
I edited this meme together with some
Godzilla audio clips what do you think
sir
[Music]
no no
you'll have to do better than that okay
okay
[Music]
he's ringing his Bell he's bringing his
belt
[Music]
oh yeah
oh it makes it like you're gonna punch
him you're gonna get a split kick in
here come on
okay yeah
now we're cooking
yeah I got a little wind-up yeah buddy
oh yeah that's nice let's go flip kicks
someone's button mashing in here
let's go Circle down
oh
you know it's funny the lightning bolts
are the most dated looking effect in
this movie
[Laughter]
they really are when he gets so ripped
he's not just rip the entire film I'm
okay I'm just half dead and
all that yeah the water's reinforcements
are still hitting the beachhead Live
Support
oh
things are happening but
we still haven't found the hostages yet
seemed like a monster or something oh
yeah
yeah he's back
unlimited power
hey do it
[Laughter]
my mama didn't raise no fool baby damn
straight
damn straight I should have stayed at
Microsoft oh
so Windows XP was your fault or
Millennium Edition that's the one he
designed his Millennium Edition since
1994.
you could have saved us from that he was
a little preoccupied where are you where
are you going
oh my God are we really doing the the
science experience this is awesome get
Spotlight yeah
this locker room looks like a laser tag
place or like a haunted house oh yes oh
no got him with the kitty claws Vega
where were we oh lucky number seven what
happened to the Purity combat this is
merely superconductor electromagnetism
surely you've heard of it
it levitates my desk where I ride the
saddle of the world oh they're talking
about harnessing this technology again
now
wow how timely
oh look at them kicks
I never had a pair of light up shoes I
don't think maybe maybe a little I want
those not that sweet though
[Music]
I wonder if they use any of the video
game sound effects or some cheating
there's two against one come here
prepare to fight a madman and instead
you found a god
oh I am a god
[Music]
reunited and it feels so good
yes yes let's go do it
[Music]
dang not bad nice
I know people are strong is when they
break the training equipment
[Music]
yes
cook his face cook him he's gonna have a
seven sunburn yeah
[Music]
that was a funny flip
that's what I'm talking about I want
some of these paintings
tell me man
he's palpes now there's a face he was
making though was so good
wow
you know big respect to Raul Julia
yeah this oh that kick nice
got that spinning Van Damme kick wow
please hurry
oh tears of joy
sorry man can't play no more
it's been fun dude I wish we could do it
again
[Music]
never felt so validated by someone
before
our boss is the enemy our freedom and
peace these people have come from all
over the world to stop him if
[Music]
invite you sir
Max opportunity
oh no
if only you could sue after this I
almost feel bad for him
[Music]
then give
buddy
my man
evacuated
we helped yeah we held it up too you
know we contributed we have to go this
whole place is gonna go up I got you
back my friend don't like this oh I
missed your tone for my part in this
evil if good men do nothing that is evil
enough damn thoughtful guy gotta say
didn't he have hair before he did was
that like a two pair to get burned off
what's going on there
oh I mean I assume the scientists know
something we don't but it seems like the
both of them are just gonna die yeah
right
hold on YouTube very good very good this
is stupid I'm done I'm done with all
this crime stuff want this gun anymore I
even like bison
[Music]
he's got his accurate costume
little shorts in his his beef posture
right severance pay
wow look at that gash
oh no
I think it is he told us to leave
we did the right thing
well it still feels pretty wrong to me
you said it
Kyle hey yeah Lieutenant make
need a vacation
I wish I knew
oh on the way out yeah
yes of course of course somebody was
chopping onions for the rations sir
no longer mid
straight to awesome
bison box
how about that interview
sure
oh flirty oh my don't jeopardize your
journalistic integrity all right
[Music]
yes
oh my God I love that I guess she had to
turn around got this flash page that was
awesome God was this was this whole
movie oh wow
God
wow that was fun that was a lot of fun
it's time once again for the good
morning Shadow Pop Quiz do you know what
it says on the bottom of Coke bottles
and bison's army oh
there you go
I was gonna say we're gonna have to like
pull up the list of of all the
of all the characters just in case we
missed oh yeah somebody because this is
like jam-packed full of yeah
obviously legit
but I thought that was him damn I I
should have called it out because he's
only in like a couple scenes early I
think when uh I think it's like when Ryu
and Ken walk into that fight club at
first and uh he's like one of the goons
and he's always like
you know like right or left side of
frame like prominent like first goon
just out of focus like you know who is
that
um he's a prolific stunt and martial
arts actor like he's he's been in a lot
of stuff like you've seen him in a lot
of stuff I know him best I think from uh
Gross Point Blank he plays Like A Silent
Assassin and he has this whole like
extended sort of comedic action scene in
that that like features him directly but
okay but yeah he's been in a bunch of
other martial arts joints and stuff but
uh but yeah my man what did you think of
the Cinematic masterpiece
of Street Fighter
[Laughter]
I thought it was fun uh oh I sense a
butt coming on me right now no but no no
butt like uh like guys trying to take he
didn't walk out with his severed butter
that's right nah I mean it was it was
fun you know I don't I don't know a ton
about Street Fighter but I can I
recognize like the visual accuracy to
some of the characters I think that was
fun I imagine a lot of Street Fighter
fans in the 90s probably are have hold a
lot of nostalgia for this film but yeah
I thought it was like a good time like
the soundtrack I thought it was corny
like the AGR the ADR was like a little
rough sometimes but I don't know it kind
of added to the charm of the movie you
know yeah it it is definitely one of
those movies that has a sort of uh it's
weird it has that so bad it's good
quality we're like yeah it's it's moving
at this crazy Breakneck pace and like
every set of characters we focus on or
cut to is in their own movie and every
one of them is like hyper saturated and
cranked up to 11 it's corny and campy
and Goofy but at the same time for what
this is and it's also reminiscent of a
lot of other movies like it's weird like
there's a good amount of like Indiana
Jones kind of stuff in here when you're
going like the further you get into uh
bison's Lair and all that stuff right
and certainly various like military
movies and like buddy cop Hong Kong
movies and stuff
um but the one thing I kept coming back
to is like
I don't know if this was like a a huge
budget movie or like a big Blockbuster
of a deal at the time I imagine it had
to at least have been an event but I was
like you know this movie doesn't seem
like it's hurting for a budget like it
it's got a lot of production values it's
got a huge cast and as cheesy as
everybody is like everybody for the most
part showed up like this has that bingo
card I guess of like I think you know
you've raouled Julia as the sort of
centerpiece of like this guy is the
classically trained actor who is giving
it his all he's committed and even
though this is silly he's really
commanding my attention right now and
then you have you know action guy
Jean-Claude Van Damme with the wacky dub
and then you've got like you know the
the Buddies uh in Ryu and Ken and then
uh and then you've got like your one
random uh strange stiff delivery ADR
Soldier like you know it's just you've
got so many things you've got like a
Frankenstein and a monster story
happening there's random bits of like
philosophy philosophy musing they don't
have to put in like it's yeah it's so
kitchen sinky and it's so
I think I said it earlier on like it has
that little kid like and then this
happened and then this happened and this
character comes in that this character
um right but yeah it was Mark Ellis
that's right man he helped do some of
those background projections for the
visual effects team you know we're all
the way back in 94. little baby Mark
Ellis again Lee started like the second
she was born doing a press for the birth
to 20. Ice Cube I don't know he wrote
the street fighter song what the hell
dude look out man Public Enemy yeah with
all the you gotta get the soundtrack now
right no totally gotta buy it but no
yeah to build off of what you're saying
hello cool Jay this is a stacked yeah
OST wow far side
damn geez everybody this is like the
soundtrack of the 90s uh so to build up
what you were saying yeah man I felt
that even though you saw like different
degrees in acting Styles within this
film you know within this movie you see
that like Raul Julia he's like he's
Hamming it up but but he's also like
believable in the role that he's playing
or that was really cool it felt like
everybody knew the movie that they were
in yeah and they embraced that fact
which is something I appreciated you
know and they were they were all there
for the vibe they knew this was like
this is like this is fun it was supposed
to be a fun movie in 1994 built off of
the Street Fighter property and yeah I
think you know because of that it really
shows on screen the the energy and and
effort they tried to put into it I do
agree that the is the effects were uh
pretty good for the time I imagine like
people would be really impressed with
watching it at the time like wow post
credit scenes yo did this in the 90s
oh snap
what one solar battery online oh no
perhaps is coming back
M bison returned somehow
domination
replay
rewind oh my God
and I love that his hand pops out like
Carrie
oh my God I I oh see that's the thing is
what I loved about this experience is
like yeah it's silly and stuff like that
I do think like the production values
are pretty decent given how kind of
goofy a lot of the movie is but the
thing is like this it entered a
territory it's like so bad it's good
kind of just has to happen right and
this movie obviously is is I think you
you hit it on the head it seems like
they approached this with fun but also
commitment so it's like in some ways it
does just fall into being a little bit
so bad it's good because I don't know it
is the 90s and it's like the first time
we're figuring this out and so it is a
little silly but at the same time there
are moments where I'm like you know
that's actually kind of neat or like oh
this actually looks pretty good in terms
of how they've brought you know all the
different elements of the production
design together and I do think it could
have used there's a lot of action and
there's a lot of military actions to
certainly so like it's it's fun in that
way too and there's certainly a fair
amount of martial arts and wire work and
all that I could have maybe used a
little bit more of a show-stopping
hand-to-hand fight of some kind yeah I
feel like yeah yeah that's the thing
it's like there's a good amount of
editing and there's a good amount of
coverage on that stuff where I feel like
man if they had just gone that little
extra step of like it's funny I think
it's for the better that they have that
moment where uh Ken sees them on screen
and it looks like a literal Street
Fighter level and you're like oh are
they gonna do it like the game I like
that they set that up and didn't have to
do it uh because it's like we get it
however I did think that that presented
an opportunity to like here's okay
here's a One-Shot fight so that we can
just watch the courtroom just the
opening of it and just like have the
fight start that way and then go into
like the regular fight would you like
sure the whole fight or keep it there I
mean like they'd put a lot of the Bison
guile fight in a um you know side by
side sort of thing or on you know yeah
sort of a profile perspective and uh and
that kind of hark into the game but yeah
just something that that accentuated the
choreography I think would have been a
nice kind of element to step up for this
because again I don't think the action's
bad or flat but it was like oh man if
they had really like got somebody used
to shooting like you know Hong Kong
martial arts style stuff to come in and
you know really make these moments sing
that much louder I mean like this this
movie has it's called status but I feel
like it could have like a slightly
stronger one if that element had been
just a little bit more you know
I don't know saturated or just you know
engaged yeah I could on the
craftsmanship tip I can agree with that
yeah
I will say I like the music yeah I
thought the soundtrack was really cool I
mean that's the thing is everything like
again there's like lots of fun and wacky
elements and the score too is definitely
going all over the place and there are
times where things remind you of um of
uh like there are things that reminded
me of like this sounds like a classical
piece this sounds like the planets or
something like that and then you know
you have other things that are a little
bit more like video game oriented and
then like whenever you cut to E Honda
there's like a Hawaiian lap steel
playing for some reason like it's cheeky
but at the same time again it feels like
in the in the best way because
everything's kind of like that and it
seems like a very intentional unified
Choice despite how kind of everywhere
the movie is and it's like every
character you cut to you could kind of
just have a movie just about them true
and so like it is this weird thing of
like you know like you know Chun Li
shows back up or there are moments where
like certain people will be off screen
for a while or like right Ryu and Kenny
you're like oh like I you've probably
been on an adventure this whole time
what we've been doing
Zangief sumo fight like that was off
screen for a while yeah you're like oh I
forgot they're even fighting yeah I
think that's what made me think of it
but uh but let's review our street
fighters here because yeah Colonel guile
chunley uh Ken Kenneth Masters he just
can Tammy was uh oh that was Kylie
Minogue okay nice not bad okay we got
Ryu uh let's see General balrog was in
there all right
um um let's see okay Charlie Blanca that
was cool I like the Blanca stuff it
would have been nice to have like yeah
maybe like one more actual beat with him
but yeah yeah thunderhawks he's uh
utilize him a little more Vegas got
dollism there you go that one that one
dude and then uh yeah DJ
and I wish he got to fight oh yeah that
was that was kind of a bummer I was like
this guy is such a I I like that they
gave him like a fun personality
um sorry I think it's a general ball rug
but that would be Gerard balrog that's
the boxer right
um
it's like I know so many yeah there you
go okay I know so many Street Fighter
characters from growing up and from
playing the arcades and stuff like that
but yeah it's like there's certain ones
where you know as the gallery grows and
I think they said this is based on
Street Fighter 2. so it's like there's
so many names and stuff that I would
recognize and then you know there's so
many other like Mortal Kombat names that
you record like this this was not that
this is like a direct representation of
the games but I was like okay so the
vibe is like Mortal Kombat is more
Supernatural and horror influence
whereas like Street Fighter is more like
military with a slight kind of sci-fi
kiss on it yeah you know it's sort of
how this this representation made it
feel yeah that's that's the thing I got
from it I'm not like a huge Street
Fighter person I don't know like a ton I
played like very very casual yeah I
could play some Marvel vs Capcom so like
I recognize some of these guys but yeah
I thought it was it was really cool you
know it made me want to see a modern one
to see like what they would do now with
this property yeah yeah absolutely well
I mean you know we've got the Legend of
Chun-Li film that we could always check
out someday
um and it's air can contrast and it is
kind of fun and interesting to see what
characters got changed because yeah it's
like you have Dr dollism Who you know I
think is a like a game fighter and so
that character has been like completely
changed and I feel like they took so
much of his aesthetic and just made it
to set dressings and stuff like that but
uh but yeah cool to see early uh mignon
see Jean-Claude Van Damme and two it's
like you have so many people who have
become prolific and and so many other
people who are like from more like
mid-level stuff like it's it's
interesting who you know Grew From This
versus who you know maybe siphoned off
into more specifically martial arts
based stuff or like B-movie stuffer or
off I like you know kind of outside the
main Hollywood bubble sort of stuff I
only recognize like a handful of people
this is a 35 million dollar budget so I
think it's money I mean it made a
hundred million worldwide so I mean like
enough like I don't know I'm sure the
business was a bit different back then
and you probably maybe didn't need to
make quite as much as you do now but but
yeah I don't know this seems like it
certainly had all the resources to be as
much movie as it needed to be without
hurting for it and uh and while yeah
every fighting game is going to have
some kind of weirdness and translation I
still thought that for for the for the
you know amount of like fun and
bounciness it had it never bored me it
never you know got on my nerves even
though certain characters get changed
and you know maybe watered down as a
result still you feel like you've got a
substantial amount of game characters
and stuff like that I'm sure there are
many more like uh uh you know different
fight level Landscapes that you know
probably flew past me just in this this
current uh moment because it's been a
while since I would have played a Street
Fighter game but uh but yeah you have
this story where at least even if you're
not getting a bunch of one-on-one fights
you get a lot of opportunities for
different characters both uh you know
Street Fighters and shadowy warriors to
fight one another to fall on different
sides of the line and then to I thought
they did a fun game of teasing where
it's like oh yeah we're about to throw
down and then oh [__] Colonel guy will
burst through the wall now there's like
a whole other thing happening and and
yeah like even if it's not like a
one-to-one translation of the source
material this this felt like about as
good as this could go in a fun kind of
cheeky sort of way for the time you know
for my money like I I had such a blaster
watching this yeah yeah I mean I don't
know like I said I don't know a ton
about uh Street Fighter as a property
but I I was watching it taking it for
what it was you know I've I feel like
maybe I would have been more like that's
not how it is if I was like a huge fan
of the property maybe maybe people who
are huge fans
are like that maybe they're not maybe
they're just grateful for the fact that
they have a Street Fighter movie to
represent what they like on the big
screen uh but yeah I think you know a
lot of the sentiments you shared I
thought were uh of similar mind to
myself you know just like I like the
just the different Dynamics we got to
explore and all of the
yeah the fact that they made you like
wait for the fights you know and just
you know what I'd like to see in like
more cool fights in the beginning sure
but like when you get to see them
towards the end it's awesome so yeah I
would say I had a good time with it you
know not being too critical no alcohol
required no alcohol required well all
right team what'd you guys think of the
Street Fighter motion picture did you
grow up on this is this a Blasphemous
take on your favorite video game or is
this an underrated gem you let us know
down below also comment with your
favorite Street Fighter character in
fact before we get out of here who's
your favorite character in the movie
Zangief baby thank you with those
eyebrows I mean I kind of gotta meet you
there I mean as much as I love DJ and as
much as you know shouts out to to Damian
Chapa holding it down as Ken uh yeah Zen
geef boy he he really understood the
assignment and he was just like I don't
know whenever we cut to you just just
eyes browse that's all we need you never
don't know what he's thinking yeah guys
comment below leave us your thoughts and
before we get out of here let's do a
patreon
pandemic Jones we nominate you as the
next DLC character in the street fighter
franchise what does pandemic Jones's
look for for his character oh pandemic
Jones he wears a big old hazmat suit yes
I like it yeah and uh Indiana Jones hat
and Indiana Jones hat you know yeah he's
one of those characters he's one of
those characters who you never actually
see there like inner form but yeah he's
like a combination of like a
swashbuckling Adventurer but also a
Hazmat you know uh uh you know Wrangler
guy yeah yeah I like it you know he has
his whip but he also has like little
masks he like he'll throw some stuff at
you he can throw it yeah dangerous viral
chemicals at you yeah totally dude
pandemic Jones I love this I cannot wait
to play as you and then fight one of our
other patrons whoever we decide on the
next fighting type of movie that's who
you're gonna be versing so keep an eye
out now you gotta watch all this shout
out to know but anyway we love you stay
pledged
um because you know as they say pay to
play but no we appreciate your love and
generosity every month my dude and we
will catch you next time much love and
uh and yeah